Qué puede salir de este encuentro se
espera una eventual y pronta reanudación
de los diálogos entre ambas partes
sí abrió gracias parecería En este
momento está abierta la posibilidad de
diálogo de cierto que ese diálogo ha
estado ocurriendo durante todo este
tiempo ellos han estado hablando pero
esas conversaciones por ahora no han
arrojado mayor luz nosotros tenemos la
expectativa que el apoyo de la comunidad
internacional concretamente de Francia
Colombia Argentina pueda
impulsar necesarios acuerdos para poder
salir de latolladero político en el que
se encuentra Venezuela ahora Qué
significa para el gobierno venezolano de
Nicolás maduro que los diálogos sean
respaldados por un país como Francia que
desde 2019
desconoció la figura de maduro como
líder legítimo de su país
soy bueno lo hizo lo lo hizo también
prácticamente toda Europa yo sí creo que
en principio hay una suerte del
reconocimiento de la realidad política
venezolana que es compleja Es verdad que
Nicolás Maduro tiene un problema serio
de legisnidad pero al mismo tiempo es
cierto que el que está al frente del
gobierno y quien tiene el poder es
Nicolás maduro y el reconocer esa
realidad es parte de la necesidad de
establecer este camino de negociación y
diálogo para poder resolver la situación
interna venezolana y por el otro lado
estoy convencido que Europa quiere
liberarse del problema en el que se
hallado sometida con el punto energético
es decir evidentemente Venezuela es un
país exportador de petróleo capacidad
para exportar gas y Esta es una
necesidad en este momento en el ámbito
europeo por lo que es importante también
para Europa lograr un camino de solución
a fin de poder tener acceso a estos
recursos que en estos momentos Son
imprescindibles